[Music]
welcome back to the Rich Eisen show and
uh Brockman on this day in which a video
that went viral today of Stuart Scott
doing the the flu game twenty two years
ago on SportsCenter tonight it's only
fitting that my next guest is here today
and the reason why is when I started off
at K RCR TV in Redding California as the
sports anchor at five o'clock in the
afternoon at eleven o'clock at night
between 1994 and 1996 the number of
times I did highlights of mitchrichman
for the Sacramento Kings on my 11
o'clock broadcast 11 I've lost track the
point of my dad I would send him tapes
my father would say how do you say
mitchrichman so well that it's Richmond
you say it so fast but at any rate the
fact that I'm now on a show with my name
on it and I look at you and I see you
here it gives me in a sense of
accomplishment because of who you are
and what you stand for and how your
friends are the good buddy monitor yeah
great to see you here thanks pal
he's essentially what I am saying what
about that game last night oh man what a
game what a game I mean you know it was
the excitement before the game where you
know you you really and truly know how
great Kevin Durant is you know coming
off of not playing for five weeks and
any coming nails the first three threes
that he shoots just some just amazing
performance you can see first quarter
you could see the rest of the team he
was he jolted the rest of the team you
could see he told the series he jolted
the series he jumped to the strategies
he is that why the hell do we need to
see that to realize what a difference
maker he is for some people match it's
just I think you it's nuts to me yeah
sometimes you be in the moment and you
know you don't see him and you know you
just think that the greatness that he
has I think that's the confidence that
Met made him come back you know you look
at the success that he's had in the
playoffs a guy walked on the court he's
averaging 30 points a game it doesn't
matter if LeBron is guarding him
whoever's guarding him he has put up big
numbers against anyone even against the
Warriors when they lost him and it was
up there
but he's just a tremendous tremendous
players and he will go down as one of
the best now you tell me again with your
14 seasons the NBA your Hall of Fame
resume I'm in a position where I talk
into a microphone every day mm-hmm and I
have so many others in my business
industry do the same and I hear all the
conversation in the talk and the talk of
legacy and the talk of what people are
saying and I think many athletes hear it
they really don't absorb it but Durant
might be different in the fact that he
has burner accounts on Twitter and
things of that nature where he's all I
hear about him is he's very sensitive
guy do you think any of the conversation
about his legacy his joining the team
that he couldn't beat despite winning
two NBA Finals MVP for them that all
that conversation that he doesn't really
want to play from anymore etcetera
factored into him playing last night do
you think any of that factor well I
think probably a percentage of that
because we we've been hearing that for
how long you know even when he grew up
there when the ugh join the Warriors
they were talking about you know he's
joining the best team in the world so
he's he's hurting his legacy I'm pretty
sure some of that creeped in his mind
but I think the most important thing
that that creeped in his mind is that if
he didn't get paid he would still be
playing this game and he's one of those
guys that loves basketball loves to play
he wanted to help his team and and he
probably had some some grapes in the
back his mind but he knew that they
needed him and they needed a boost to
just to actually see him on the court I
thought he was gonna have 30 that night
but you can tell that he was just gonna
be able to to catch and shoot probably
not do anything off the dribble and I
think what happened was his instincts
just creep crept in when Ibaka pushed up
on him it's like man this guy can't
guard me and he tried to do a quick move
and Thomas what happened yeah yeah just
I think it's mine you know it says his
mind was a little head of his body at
the time and it always happens too when
you hurt when you're older player but I
think at that particular time he felt
like hey man this guy
what are you pushing up on me and he
tried and and that's what happened he
planted his foot up interesting yes
that's what you that's your observation
yes cuz you've been there yes in there
like you know it
it happens in rectly you know when you
when you retire you get a guy at you
know keep talking smack and in your mind
it's not really where your body's at
your body's a little bit behind and then
now you're trying to do some things that
you did when when you were younger or do
some things when you were healthy and
that's what happens sometimes when you
when you're when you're hurt you play
better because you know you can't do
some of the things so you really have to
concentrate on on your movement on how
you play mitchrichman hall-of-famer here
on the Rich Eisen show you spent some
time also with the Kings in the front
office correct and that's what boogie
cousins were there this is what boogie
cousins had to say last night about the
fan reaction to the injury as well as to
some of the conversation that you and I
were having about the talk in regards to
Durant right that was surrounding his
comeback go for it it's not about
basketball about everything else it's
all don't care about
trash so trash but like I said no
superstar athletes not human beings it's
always about what we can do between
those lines what's your reaction to that
mission
I'm agree with it a little bit I
definitely do agree with that but I
think in in that sense where the fans of
their reaction was quick we can win a
championship and then I you gotta praise
the the Toronto Raptors players for you
know toning that down telling telling
the the crowd to kind of hey man come on
get a grip yes let's just get a grip I
mean you know we want to win but we
don't want anyone to get injured and
like I said you know everyone is
sentient know I love Toronto Toronto is
a good place and a lot of good people in
Toronto but I think it was just in the
heat of the moment that they were like
hey man we're trying to win a
championship here and they were already
scared that Kevin Durant played so when
he came back and and and did that I
think it was just a quick reaction of
them you know trying to win a
championship but they they get they got
a group have you ever been in a
situation like that Mitch where where
fans are um no I don't think in that
sense but I mean I'm I didn't you know
no I don't think so I don't think I ever
been in the situation where the fans
black would you got her it is no
question last night again was such a
unique game and then just because as I
said at the top of the show it's an
elimination game which is always intense
obviously the NBA Finals like the team
being facing elimination is only the
two-time defending world champs that put
Durant back on the floor for the first
time in 30-plus days and the team that
has a chance to win is a team that's
representing an entire country that's
never had a shot for something like this
it really was unique and then in the
midst of all that is Kawhi Leonard yes
and how well he has been playing how
great he has been playing what did you
make of the final sequence of the the
game last night where Kawhi had the ball
in his hands for a brief bit the chance
to win it
well I thinking that and that's
since I think go to stay bitter a
wonderful job and trying to push him out
and catch at the about a half-court line
and people you know it's questioning
should he took the shot I think he would
have had an opportunity to take the shot
on one or two guys if he would have
caught in a sweet spot if he'd have had
it on the post if it had it in in his
mid range area or the free throw line
area I think he would have probably took
on two guys but at that particular time
he had to take two or three dribbles to
even get to the three-point line
and that's when they doubled him and he
made the right play he made the right
basketball player gave it to his
teammates and the rest is history
do you think Nick nurse made a mistake
calling a timeout with three minutes to
go as his team had just watched coli
score ten on unanswered points yeah I
don't like to go back to that because I
think at that time you know you know
Toronto was rolling they had the best
player in basketball and this in these
playoffs had an opportunity gonna put it
in his hands and and finish it out
Toronto played a perfect game where they
say hey we're gonna stay close as we can
and then we have an opportunity to give
it to Kauai and I mean you have to Kauai
in and win the game and he almost
single-handedly won the game but the
Golden State you got to give them credit
because they never quit the whole game
they never quit so you don't was that a
mistake do you think that that timeout
time I won't go back to that I just
think that it was some plays down the
stretch that they let cook let her we
get loose or they left clay and it was
Kauai who left clay trying to help out
on someone else and Green did an
excellent job in swinging the ball clay
did a great pump fake and got Kauai off
his feet I just think it was just the
winning in and making mistakes is it's
so close and they made they had made
some tough mistakes on two great shoes
and you cannot do that and he can't
close out the water you got to knock out
the wars yeah they got up like The
Undertaker like Tyson Fury last night
right sure we had in the studio just
last week a few more minutes left with
Mitch Richmond Basketball Hall of Famer
here in the Rich Eisen show and you're
gonna they're going to
have to try and knock out the Warriors
in Oracle one night a basketball left in
that arena now that few people thought
might actually happen what's your
favorite Oracle memory Mitch man I have
so many you know cuz you know me and
being drafted from there I have so many
great memories just playing with Chris
and Tim and those fans have been like
that even when we played it even before
we play when a Dallas was coaching it is
a great fan base there I'm gonna miss
Oracle I'm gonna miss you know going to
games in that Oakland area hopefully
they can continue that that stigma that
they have in San Francisco because
that's one of the best crowds in the
game I'm told that place is unbelievable
are you gonna believe are you going to
the game I think I'm gonna be going yes
so when you walk first walk in Oracle
when you're fresh out of Kansas State
yes coming from South Florida
yes where you you know you and Irv we're
hanging out you like what was that like
walking into Oracle first time you have
a good memory remember I think my first
game I just just remember a play to
probably average I may probably hit
about 16 17 points but the energy of the
crowd I was like man I really like this
even in 1888 I really like this they
were they were always crazy for the for
the Golden State Warriors not many of
the people around knew about go to state
wars but the people in Oakland and in
that area they loved their team well I
mean you and Mullen obviously Mullen
bringing more of the Northeast the New
York City media attention to a spot
through New York probably attention to
this Mullen was mr. st. John's
basketball yes and then timming Hardaway
and the way that he played in the three
the three of you meshed together was
particularly special yes I think and III
remember all that did you realize how
special it was when you were playing it
oh well I remember just having a great
time playing it was a it was a time
where you know I look at the Warriors
and who are you gonna double offer and
and that's what that's what it was when
we were playing with Chris and Tim if
you're gonna double mean you know Chris
and Tim was gonna have a big night if
you're gonna double Chris I think you
had to pick your spots but when you have
three players that can really
or the basketball very very hard because
one one defender if he makes one mistake
saying you know when I'm not gonna help
then you let a guy play one-on-one and
Chris was one of the best shooters I
felt like I was one of the best
one-on-one players in the game and
there's also Tim so it's very difficult
to garnish did you guys ever meet Run
DMC
of course okay what was that no give me
the first run TMZ Run DMC so it was like
a little surprised that they were gonna
actually be performing at the game when
we played the Lakers and we got an
opportunity to meet him before the game
and listen I've been watching Run DMC
you know growing up with the adidas and
everything so it it was very very
important for me to meet them and we had
a had a great time but I think we kind
of pissed off the Lakers on when we
opened up with Run DMC yeah it didn't it
didn't go too well
magic I mean magic I don't think he
thought that we should be performing we
haven't won the game yet so Run DMC you
know actually did a concert right before
the game so we were filling ourselves
start the season in 88 mm do you
remember was that 88 yeah that would no
no it was the playoffs we played the
Lakers in 91 I think yeah it's the end
of your stay there stay there and you
know we had just beat we had just beat
the Lakers in LA mm-hm and we're going
home we like hey man we're feeling good
1 1 and our opportunity could kind of
kick them and run DMC
they played before the game you know
they brought us out so ok magic was
pretty pissed and not all the guys but
they got us a magic had 15 and 15 James
Worthy had 36 that oh what a team jeez
what a game makes you at 24 okay no
slaps alright put up something by the
way I would think Reverend run from
Hollis Queens that I'm very excited to
meet Mullin oh no question
I mean that well it's something yes
New York guys man I don't floor two guys
yeah well we got everybody from South
Florida stand together one of my
favorite moments was being at the Pro
Bowl
the year that it was on the mainland us
for the first time they held it in South
Florida and the place where they
practiced the players the team's
practiced at st. Thomas Aquinas yeah
well Mike ok ok with the school ok ok so
we did all of our shows from st. Thomas
and Michael Irvin showing up there Elvis
was in the bill oh no no they love that
guy here man Oh as Mike and he knew that
they loved him yes yes yeah it was just
great to watch come back there he loves
walking in the front door
you ought to me with all the fanfare
that's what he does bad boy he's an
entertainer
Irv isn't any entertainer he's in it
could he could opened up for you in 1991
I mean that's that's that's that's
that's right around there yes yes oh and
he's excited to it cuz you know today I
do believe is 88 days until the
beginning of the NFL season all right 88
Michael Irvin right well we will find
out if that's true on Instagram or
Twitter we should we should you know
he's gonna put that well it's definitely
I know on 84 days to this season he
won't be talking about Alvin Harper just
imagine being on the other side of the
field Michael or ever for saying give me
the ball Troy no Corey should be saying
it's right Roy Troy Troy should be Saint
Troy Vincent Troy Aikman I mean for sure
hey good to see you Mitch hey thanks for
having me this spot is open for you
anytime okay man I'm right down the
street okay I'm here now it's true that
when you came on you were just supposed
to be just a one segment guest with her
but you stayed the whole show I stayed
the whole show man why not and they came
back the next day
yeah then came back and
came back the next day I couldn't let
Michael get all the South Florence I had
to come and get me some some air time in
Richmond 23 on Twitter at Mitch Rock
Richmond 23 on Instagram I put that
thing together man you know what I mean
I gotta put it together please you're
talking to somebody whose name is on a
mug and on anything I understand about
it yeah I got a bread methane-rich
Rock Aizen just doesn't flow it just
does not flow Mitch Richmond here on the
Rich Eisen shota for more of the Rich
Eisen show tune - audience Channel 239
on DirecTV for free on BR Live or
download the Rich Eisen show app